how's going with my name is pure Pat
welcome to another amnesia custom story
this one is called discipline ends yeah
it's very very Swedish dude it seems
really nice I gave him it all he
contacted me and he said this would you
like I can't talk this is really awkward
welcome to a session to familiarize with
discipline and people start imagining
the Hamlet
all the way
the story is based on real events and
allegedly occurred inside the nation
like garlic's hands that girl looks
drunk
press Continue if you dare to witness
her and relieve every hair say about
this opponent book stalled and it's a
really unique naming chose to go in I
don't know I guess it means disprin NC
a-- village i don't really know what
this potentia is but here oh did you
hear that is a grudge girl i'm not a big
fan of the grudge girl I mean she's
pretty hot I'd give it a 4 out of 10
that's not on at all actually I don't
know what I'm talking about I don't know
she's she's a bit hairy and I got weird
really bad nightmares from the grudge
game my beard going well
ha ha ha creak this face ever
alright Mackey boy presents
disprin Anthea
I like they know for centuries that have
been story surrounding a Hamid Khan wash
and its neighbor mansion discipline and
sports started for centuries I've been
sorry surrounding hamlet called flush
and its name imagine [ __ ] the quiet
forest clad mountains that surrounds
call forces dressed with scattered legs
Megan its pictures as it can be even
though they are as haunted by darkness I
thought very nice asking a local animal
here proof of the widespread
superstition I never heard of called for
a my silly for not hearsay about this
event sir sod and say that a visitor was
by the way the seller was talking to
prone in a thunderstorm everyone else
you know you're not supposed to do that
his body brought by its tainted soul had
left in this figure than empty of
essence but the energy of his spirit
still remains many a as search that they
would have experienced my national
family has felt that they were being
absurd and follow why busy think that
match other claim that they have sent
some kind of dark energy and energy
which chaos
well to live died said that knows when
country spirits will be gone soon by its
back
regardless on the frightening stories
you decide to spend a night all alone
no I don't want to go that I really
don't want to go in that after reading
that nope I'm good I'm fine here
[ __ ] alright breaths don't even worry
about it I know what I'm doing I'm an
expert like we go in here everything up
hello to B to C A to A fluence noon cool
progress right who said that right we're
fine o bouncers $25 25 $10 I love that
word authors it's what makes me want to
live
hey pot nice meeting subscribe click
tracking get your [ __ ] on me
this bugs books ain't got [ __ ] I can
climb this bookshelf
hello tinderbox e are you the one
throwing those two a [ __ ] I got [ __ ] it
I don't need a tinderbox come on man
there you go again what is that
alright I guess this is the kitchen it's
not a flying okay maybe it's like a UFO
wannabe
what else do we have in here what is uh
Tiffany ah sorry sir I'm sorry what are
you doing you can never leave me ass
[ __ ] shut up you don't know what you're
talking about but if you do it don't go
in that pit shut up I go wherever I
wanna go there's nothing here
you [ __ ] douche what is this a cat oh
I hate cats
a spoon I love spoon what are you doing
SPO come on spoon don't laugh [ __ ] me ah
what are your dad Alice panic I am NOT
evil stefana all right good
why is it shaking don't worry about it
it's your boss it doesn't make sense but
don't worry about it that made no sense
I'm sorry my guy welcome to this Boone
ethical Starling I have left some bones
in life which you're allowed to eat if
you want the house is reasonably clean
so don't make a mess I will come back on
Saturday clean the further call wash
company IRA side room to be four you can
triage on buddy
well thank you Ann Marie you're quite
the pickle aren't you glad to pick you
first what the hell are you talking
about
what is this [ __ ] shaking bad about
Zapata
I mean I'm Stefano oh what the [ __ ] what
I out but that one I spent all over my
screen that is disgust ah [ __ ] you got
Stefano hey Diane hello my screen is now
a shower that is disgusting alright cool
let's go let's go
don't leave it what am I we're fine
Claire fine a shot
what are you doing break dancing no no
oh hell no oh hell no
don't hit me don't hit me don't Cameron
okay okay fine fine fine fine fine fine
we're going up I'm going up whether it's
what the [ __ ] what are you doing
alright don't even worry about to be was
it oh ok uh alright I can find the sleep
somehow no it all right
you'll have this bed and I'll have the
other one
ah oh is it night now quite enjoying
this
I stole that wisely I don't snore though
maybe a little bit but Jenna
Jace's Christ how long are you gonna
sleep as a crow by there and see that
thing so far now a sleeping well we
totally did choose out of it
Oh creepy this is action
[ __ ] mrs. shower head you're not
supposed to fly
I'm fried Wow let's calm down Jason
I was going for the shower he's done
this thing is my destiny to my death
but I
what in the hell this is the basement
what is that okay oh no that is I hate
that girl she just wants a hug I know
but Jesus case case
whoa
oh no give me that
the bottom wake up wake the [ __ ] up
bah-bah-bah-bah-bah did it what
alright Pig let's go alright Jesus
Christ the power without didn't it
someone added into your friendless
Kayleigh
Jesus Christ except what what's that I
saw I'll take that I can't take it
I'll take this done fine klappa stop
whoa shut vodka I do not like a doctor
what is this music [ __ ] cha-cha papa oh
no so good to see it scheme a fit else
yeah [ __ ] what's going on here
[ __ ] jump scares bro I do not
appreciate it crowbar do something at
the point of this room
others come on bro no get more bueno bro
bro Hammes shut up crackler i'll
updating
do you like the wallpapers alright
alright we need to [ __ ] some women I
mean kill some guests
alright one of yous like you say why
don't we use this crowbar
probably on another floor I didn't
really investigate that much let's go
damn it
I [ __ ] sprinting what are you doing
here yeah ah fine okay oh hello what I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
yeah disgusting
ah the barricade is locked
crowbar time [ __ ] the salon has
courted off-duty electricians
[ __ ] me what are we doing about this
Bruna my Night Watch ow
don't close that door okay fine what in
the hell ever fine I'm fine I'm fine
this baby's babies can't hurt me I'll
just kick them with our shower okay
seriously what am I supposed to do
why do you look so evil that way about
10:00 I do not work with the bounce all
right
and I did not kidnap Zapata all right
all right
trusty totally toe to my guts
afros fellows I know I don't aim in a
hurry now what are we doing the Kings
through what is this toilet this stuff
sir I can't can't leave it for whatever
[ __ ] reason
now
I showered whoa whoa whoa hello don't
care they whatever you do oh yeah